>>> NEW DETAILS THIS MORNING OF
THE KILLING OF THE LEADER OF AL
QAEDA AND THE WORLD'S MOST
WANTED TRORIST, AYMAN AL
ZAWAHIRI.
PRECISE NATURE OF THE DRONE
ATTACK, AND THE DAMAGE SEEMED TO
BE LIMITED TO THIS TINY PORTION
OF THE BUILDING WHERE HE WAS
SUGGESTS IT COULD BE THE WORK OF
A SECRETIVE U.S. WEAPON, A
MODIFIED HELLFIRE MISSILE
NICKNAMED "THE FLYING GINSU."
TOM FOREMAN IS JOINING US NOW.
TELL US ABOUT THIS MODIFIED
HELLFIRE MISSILE.
>> WE CAN TELL YOU WHAT WE
BELIEVE WE KNOW.
THE TRUTH IS THE PENTAGON, THE
DOD, THEY DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THIS THING.
THIS IS WHAT IS BELIEVED TO BE,
BASED ON A LOT OF MILITARY
WATCHERS WHO STUDIED IT CLOSELY,
IT IS A VERSION OF A HELLFIRE
MISSILE, MEANING FIVE FEET LONG,
ABOUT 100 POUNDS, AND WHAT MAKES
IT UNIQUE IS THIS.
YOU CAN'T SEE THE TWO IN THE
BACK, BUT THERE ARE SIX BLADES
THAT AS THIS FLIES TOWARD A
TARGET, THEY POP OUT AT THE LAST
POSSIBLE MOMENT, CREATING A
KINETIC ATTACK FORCE.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS NO EXPLOSION,
JUST A TREMENDOUS FORCE MOVING
THROUGH A TARGET, SO SOMETHING
ABOUT AS BIG AS A SCREEN, IS
EXPOSED TO THE ATTACK AND
NOTHING ELSE AROUND IT.
IT IS A VERY UNUSUAL WEAPON.
AND, AGAIN, THEY DON'T WANT TO
TALK ABOUT IT, IN PART BECAUSE
IT IS SO UNUSUAL, AND SUCH A
SURPRISE ON THE BATTLEFIELD NOW.
>> I MEAN, GIVEN THE NICKNAME, I
THINK IT ANSWERS SOME OF THE
QUESTION.
BUT REALLY EXPLAIN TO FOLKS HOW
THIS DIFFERS FROM OTHER HELLFIRE
MISSILES.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT A NORMAL
HELLFIRE MISSILE, YOU SEE SOME
LOADED ON A DRONE HERE, WE
TALKED ABOUT THE SIDE, THEY'RE
NOT TERRIBLY BIG.
THEY HAVE BEEN AROUND FOR
DECADES, DEVELOPED AS ANTI-TANK
WEAPONS.
THEY ARE USED TO  EDD  EDD TO F
INTO BUILDINGS, THEY'RE VERY
COMMON AND VERY WIDELY USED.
THE BIG DIFFERENCE IS THIS, IF
YOU LOOK AT THE FIRING OF A
NORMAL HELLFIRE MISSILE, IT
TAKES OFF, AND IT IS CARRYING A
WARHEAD.
IT IS BEING GUIDED TOWARD A
TARGET, AND WHEN IT HITS, IT IS
GOING TO EXPLODE.
THE BLAST AREA WHEN IT EXPLODES
WOULD BE POTENTIALLY ABOUT AS
BIG AS A FOOTBALL FIELD, IN
TERMS OF WHERE PEOPLE WOULD BE
IN DANGER.
THAT'S A BIG IMPACT.
AND BEAR IN MIND, THIS THING IS
MOVING VERY, VERY FAST.
THE DIFFERENCE WITH THIS ONE,
YOU GO BACK TO THE RX-9, YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT ONE THAT DOES NOT
HAVE A BLAST AREA AT ALL.
YOU CAN'T CALL THIS A BOMB.
IT IS A KINETIC WEAPON, IT IS A
KINETIC MISSILE.
THAT'S ITS PURPOSE.
THAT'S WHY THEY SAY YOU'RE MUCH
LESS LIKELY TO HIT ANYONE OTHER
THAN YOUR TARGET, BECAUSE THE
DAMAGE AREA IS RIGHT IN ONE
SPOT.
>> IT LIMITS THAT COLLATERAL
DAMAGE THAT U.S. DRONE STRIKES
HAVE FACED SO MUCH CRITICISM
BECAUSE OF.
WHEN YOU'RE SPECIFICALLY, TOM,
LOOKING AT THE AFTERMATH OF THIS
STRIKE THAT WE SAW IN KABUL,
WHAT SUGGESTS THAT THIS COULD BE
THE WEAPON THAT WAS USED?
>> THE SAME THING THAT WOULD
SUGGEST TO YOU.
LOOK AT THE HOUSE.
THERE IS NO SIGN OF A GIANT
BLAST HERE.
YOU TALK ABOUT A BLAST THAT
COULD REACH OUT ACROSS A
FOOTBALL FIELD.
THERE IS NO SIGN OF THAT HERE.
THERE IS LIMITED CONTAINED
DAMAGE, YOU DON'T SEE BURN
MARKS, YOU DON'T SEE BLAST
FRAGMENTATION, NONE OF THE
THINGS YOU EXPECT TO SEE FROM A
NORMAL EXPLOSION OUT THERE.
I WANT TO POINT OUT THE SPEED OF
THIS THING.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
THIS IS MOVING CLOSE TO 1,000
MILES AN HOUR, ABOVE THE SPEED
OF SOUND AT SEA LEVEL.
SO EVEN IF YOU WERE
THEORETICALLY LOOKING FOR
THREATS OUT THERE, YOU WOULD NOT
HEAR IT APPROACHING, BECAUSE IT
IS COMING TOO FAST.
AT THE SPEED IT IS TRAVELING, IF
YOU ACTUALLY SPOTTED THIS
RELATIVELY SMALL MISSILE A MILE
AWAY, YOU WOULD HAVE FOUR
SECONDS BEFORE IT WAS ON TOP OF
YOU.
THAT'S HOW FAST IT IS MOVING.
SO THAT'S WHAT MAKES IT SUCH A
DEVASTATING WEAPON.
PEOPLE DON'T SEE IT COMING, THEY
DON'T KNOW IT'S COMING AND WHEN
IT STRIKES, IF IT IS GUIDED
PROPERLY AND IT IS BEING GUIDED,
THIS COULD ACTUALLY BE GUIDED BY
SOMEBODY IN THE UNITED STATES,
THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE TO BE OVER
THERE, WHEN THEY TAKE IT INTO
THEIR TARGET, THE GOAL IS TO HIT
SPECIFICALLY WHAT THEY'RE AFTER,
AND NOTHING ELSE, AND LOOK AT
THE BUILDING.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE AN EXPERT
TO SAY I DON'T THINK THING BLEW
UP IN THERE.
SOMETHING VERY VIOLENT, VERY
DRAMATIC HAPPENED, BUT I DON'T
THINK IT WAS AN EXPLOSION
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE AN
EXPLOSION.
THAT'S THE SIGNATURE OF THIS
MISSILE, WHICH NOW APPEARS TO
HAVE BEEN USED ABOUT A DOZEN
TIMES IN RECENT YEARS THROUGH
YEMEN AND IN IRAQ, A FEW OTHER
PLACES OVER THERE.
>> YEAH.
LOOK, CLEARS UP A LOT OF
QUESTIONS THAT I THINK PEOPLE
HAVE LOOKING AT THESE PICTURES.
TOM, THANK YOU.